زد انفاقك تزداد قوه ومكمل قوه الجيوش في
تحديثها تعلم الصين وان قدرتها الدفاعيه
عامل حاسم في الرضع والمواجهه لا يسعها
هنا تجاهل ما يفرضه التصعيد المستجد بقوه
مع الولايات المتحده من تحديات
تتعاظم تلك التحديات مع ما كشف من تغيير
في توجهات الاستراتيجيات الدفاعيه
الامريكيه تجاه بيجن
ما عدا الامر قاصر على المناوره المعهوده
مع الحلفاء في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادي وعلى اعتاب الصين انما هي الاهبه
لاندلاع حرب هناك بل والفوز بها تلك مهمه
فوج جديد من مشاه البحريه الامريكيه يخوض
تمرينا هو في الاساس نسخه حياه او موت من
لعبه الغميضه انه الاستعداد لاختبار
مفاهيم قتاليه قد يحتاجها البانتاجون يوما
ما في حال اندلعت تلك الحرب
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه التي تكشف
ذلك تقول ان المناورات التي اقيمت بجنوب
ولايه كاليفورنيا لعبت فيها قواعد عسكريه
نائيه دور سلسله من جزر المحيط الهادي
يفترض المخططون العسكريون ان اي معركه
المستقبليه محتمله مع الصين قد تحدث فيما
يشير اليه البنك غالبا باسم سلسله الجزر
الاولى وتشمل
وصولا الى ماليزيا وكذلك بحر جنوب الصين
والجزر المتنازع
ليس سرا تدهور العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه
بسبب ما تصفه واشنطن بالتحركات العدوانيه
ضد تايوان الى جانب ما تقول انها محاولات
صينيه لترويع حلفاء امريكا في المنطقه
بينهم اليابان لذلك كله يخشى ان اندلاع
حرب كبيره في المحيطين الهندي والهادي
اصبح محتملا الان اكثر من اي وقت مضى منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ذاك ما يراه خبراء
عسكريون لكن المواجهه اذا تمت ستكون مع
جيش صيني قدر تقرير لوزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه انه يلحق بسرعه
بمصافي القوات الغربيه
بالنسبه
يقتصر هدف جيش التحرير الشعبي كما تسميه
بشكل اساسي على الدفاع عن مطامحه بالسياده
على حدوده لكنها لا تخفي عمله المستميت
لفرض التفوق الاقليمي واعاقه اي تدخلات
خارجيه في المنطقه